hey there i'm philip molina and i am so
excited to finally have some road one
material to break down here i had the
beginning of this year i went out on the
limb and i said that the only movie that
might perform better than captain
america civil war this year is gonna be
rogue one and considering that the
teaser trailer alone already has like 30
million views in just a few days i think
i might be right and as you probably
know this is the story of how the rebels
got the plans for the original Death
Star and these are the events that
kicked off our entire introduction to
the Star Wars universe at the beginning
of a new hope but this spin-off is
pretty much all new characters and while
you might think that it's a pretty
obvious story spoiler alert the Death
Star plans do make it to Princess Leia
it's actually a completely unpredictable
story because Star Wars Canon for this
time period was totally erased and we
kind of have no idea what's gonna happen
to these people though I do have some
guesses but I will save those
predictions till later let's get right
into the trailer state your name for the
record
gen ah so
forgery of Imperial documents possession
of stolen property
aggravated assault resisting arrest so
right away we meet our rogue one hero
jyn erso played by Felicity Jones you
might remember her as the love interest
and theory of everything or more likely
the girl that you thought was Zooey
Deschanel and the amazing spider-man not
her
now while this character is technically
brand new to the Star Wars universe
there are a lot of theories as to what
connections
she could have to people we do already
know that is a whole can of worms and
I'm gonna save it for later in the video
if you look closely as Jin is being
escorted through the rebel base you can
see she's handcuffed and these handcuffs
do show up again later and I'll point
them out in a few minutes also note this
guy that's doing the escorting I'm a
little thrown off by the characters on
his helmet because they aren't standard
Arabic and if you know what this says
let me know but this one character kind
of looks like an upside-down Arabic
should let her peek that means police
maybe is this helping at all let me know
if you know what that means but moving
on throughout this sweeping shot we
realized that we're at a very familiar
rebel base complete with X wings and a
little golf droids and what's cooler is
that when you see the vine-covered stone
walls you put it together and you're
like oh this is yahan 4 and we're on the
inside of the same rebel base that we
saw in a new hope specifically this is
the great temple of Massassi Nastase
Massassi i don't remember so put
together what we've got so far and
you've got an interesting question why
does Jin look like she's a prisoner on a
rebel base listening to the charges
against her you hear she forged Imperial
documents which you would think the
rebels would be like all about
so either was the Empire that arrested
her and the rebellion had wise I may be
rescued her or the rebels arrested her
for maybe snooping around they didn't
know she was or something like that and
then once they see these charges forgery
of Imperial documents possession of
stolen property
aggravated assault resisting arrest and
this is all just me guessing by the way
maybe they're like oh and that's why we
totally are gonna recruit you now Jin by
the way is clearly inspired by Han Solo
the type of ro
badass who might be a bit of a criminal
herself but also might be exactly what
the rebels need since plain dirty with
rogues is one of the only ways that they
can try and gain an upper hand over the
Empire it's interesting that this movie
is kind of giving us our female han Solo
considering force awakens seem to give
us our female Luke now I'm just
wondering who the male Leia is gonna be
oh and uh since I brought up force
awakens I'll also point out that this
sure does feel familiar the slow piano
music opening this trailer just like the
force awakens trailer and now in this
one it's the force theme that we hear at
the beginning and hate it all you want
I'm loving this trend of like nostalgic
slowed-down piano covers of classic
movie themes I cannot explain why but it
totally works on me including one they
did it in dress world
it wasn't I guess a little weird when
they did it and ghostbusters and it was
suddenly terrifying when they did it for
the spongebob remake let's move on this
is a rebellion isn't it I rebelled and
now this beaver haired hottie
this is Mon Mothma and she's someone who
is so huge in the Star Wars universe and
yet your average fan doesn't only
remember her that well at this time in
the Star Wars timeline Mon Mothma is a
high-ranking leader in the rebellion
though technically she's a civilian but
that's nerdy to point out so I'll keep
going she's gonna go on to eventually
become the first Chancellor of the New
Republic like way in the future after a
little Java has his day but until then
she's helping the fledgling rebellion
get things started that makes a lot of
sense because this same actress
Genevieve O'Reilly played Mon Mothma in
a deleted scene in Revenge of the Sith
the last of the Star Wars prequel
trilogy and there along with some other
senators who could tell that Supreme
Chancellor Palpatine was Sidious ly
crazy she was part of the plan to form
this rebellion so she's like an OG
founder of the whole thing I also got a
call out how fantastic this casting is
because holy crap does she look exactly
the same as the original Mon Mothma that
we saw in Return of the Jedi
many Bothans died to bring us this
information by the way two things to
point out there one reminder this is not
the story of those Bothans that died to
bring those deaths are plants the
rebellion that was about the second
Death Star not the first one this story
is all about the first Death Star but
the second thing to point out it's so
funny to me to pretend that instead of
saying
many Bothans she's saying man II both
Hans died to bring this information as
in manual both Hans Mon Mothma tiny
little boyfriend I'm totally taking this
from a comic called tagging pink but it
just cracks me up so much to think of
little Manny both hands
Mama's lost lover many
it's died to bring us this information
that look now makes so much sense thank
you - top shelf fun for sharing that oh
and remember how great I said the match
was for the actress here well let's kick
up the brightness I'm gonna point out
this guy a lot of signs are pointing to
this guy being general Dodona from a new
hope I don't know the hair is it's like
not as swoopy so if that is him I just
don't know if they nails the casting as
much as they did with Mothma but our
next introduction is of diego luna's
character who we still have no idea who
he's playing he's got a flight jacket
and a rank insignia of captain and while
that's not a lot to go on many people
are thinking he might be filling in for
kyle katarn and most of you are like
kyle Kahoot so really quick i'll say
this story is about getting the plans
for the Death Star - the rebellion it
was told another time in a really old
computer game from the 90s where the
character of Kyle Katarn was tasked with
getting those same plans to the rebels
so note the similarities and jacket
style and favorite arm positions Qatar
was a fan favorite character and he
actually ended up appearing in lots of
stories
he's a former stormtrooper by the way
like Finn and he grew a beard a lot like
the one we see here now even though
those old stories are no longer
considered canon they've been like erase
kind of here's why this speculation is
not the craziest thing not only is the
storyline similar but Kyle he had a
female partner who was another rebel
agent but she was also an ex-criminal ex
Mugler also kind of like han Solo and
while her name is not Jin or so it's not
that far away from that her name is Jan
force ginger so Jan ors it's very close
and you can see that these two are
definitely some sort of partners since
he's obviously keeping an eye on her
here
that's his marm so he's watching from
behind the shadows and that's probably
him watching from behind there and it's
also him whose life she seems to protect
when she shields him from that blast
though I don't know who that person with
the trigger in their hand is let me know
if you have a guess who that is
but anyway you can see how this all
could be something like kyle katarn as a
rebel agent and he's got an eye on this
chick who is some sort of good guy
terrorist maybe and her and her people
are messing with the empire on there
oan and as maybe she's leading a couple
of the original trilogy stormtroopers
into a trap her fellow good guy
terrorist maybe blows them up and she
realizes oh this guy's here and she
tries to protect him and then he's like
hey I want to bring you back to work
with us and they're like hey I'm Mon
Mothma we got a job for you and she
looks at him and she's like what have
you gotten me into and yeah this is all
huge speculation for what this movie is
about but doesn't it kind of sound legit
just by my terrible voice acting anyway
this Kyle Katarn and Jan ors theory is
not the only theory for Fujin or so
might be i've got another one to drop on
you later in the video but enough about
that two other things I will point out
about this section before I move on one
is that we get our first glimpse of this
droid behind Jin and that might be who
Alan Tudyk is playing but more on him
later - this is a really good moment to
remind people this movie takes place
when most Jedi are either dead or have
gone into hiding so it's not really
about the Jedi or the force if I not
gonna be a lightsabers in there rather
this movie is about the war part of Star
Wars we're gonna have bombs and guns and
guerrilla tactics it's not crazy that
the cinematographer of this movie he
shot zero dark thirty which is a gritty
realistic movie about an elite team
having to infiltrate an enemy base this
movie isn't gonna have elegant duels
it's gonna have nasty melees and that
but still set in the Star Wars universe
sounds amazing
now let's move on we have a mission for
you
a major weapons test is imminent we need
to know what it is how to destroy it is
that clear yes okay in this section we
get that transport shot of gin looking
out the window and while mon mothma is
explaining the plot of the movie that
lens flare moment could possibly be a
shout-out to force awakens director JJ
Abrams who is super famous for using
them and then there's this incredibly
epic shot of the imperial star destroyer
and the Death Star's laser dish being
assembled this bit here is definitely
worth dissecting first off this is not
the first time we've seen the same Death
Star under construction it actually goes
to show just how long it takes to build
one of these things since this moment is
just under 20 years earlier then
focusing on this Star Destroyer for a
second force awakens did a great job of
showing us the scale of one of these
things and so when we focus on that and
then shift our focus to the Death Star
that really showcases just how massive
the Death Star is it makes sense that
you would confuse it for a moon we're
gonna be heading for that small moon
that's no moon it's a space station
especially when you compare to the scale
of a Star Destroyer or a banana and then
there's the shadow wiping by in the
background which feels both like a
reference to how Lucas loved to
transition between the scenes in the
movies in fact I wouldn't be surprised
if this is a transition moment in the
movie but it also reminds me of JJ
Abrams opening shot in the force awakens
where the Star Destroyer shadow eclipses
jakku now in that movie there's also
some symbolism going on with the light
side and the dark side in that shot and
I'm not gonna bring that up about rogue
one just yet but if you want to know
more about that concept watch the other
video about all the symbolism in Easter
eggs they snuck into force awakens as
for this guy talking to jinn his voice
sounds like he was the one reading off
the list of crimes earlier stolen
property aggravated assault
is that clear and his command square
suggests that he's a general maybe the
two bull's-eyes on the top right though
are pretty unique it suggests he's got
some sort of special assignment maybe
special forces or intelligence which is
spy stuff and you gotta love that jinn
is giving him the Han Solo sarcasm with
her yes just like his fake respect he
gave to Leia
early on look
fullness okay let's move on okay now
that was a short section but there is so
much to go over and just let's do
seconds first off here's where that
siren kicks in and it makes you feel
uneasy as you watch the whole rest of it
a lot of people are claiming that it's
the famous Star Wars Imperial siren
sound and some people have is their
ringtones which is a pretty annoying
ringtone just say no hood they think
it's that sped up and the pitch is
shifted I think people are forgetting
that's the exact same siren sound
without any alterations that was used in
a new hope when the rebels were
attacking the Death Star
we count 30 rebel ships low beta now
using a siren and a trailer felt really
familiar for some reason you might be
thinking of the pretty intense
Prometheus trailer
check this out just like rogue ones
trailer that trailer was for a movie
that was a sort of prequel sort of
spin-off movie of a much older sci-fi
fantasy movie from the 70s and the newer
trailer is using a siren in a reference
to the siren that blares in the original
70s movie
that's all exactly the same here except
now throw in the fact that Ridley Scott
was never gonna make a lien until he was
in a theater and was blown away by Star
Wars so it all comes full circle they're
already kind of annoying but creepy
siren now regarding the visuals of this
section we start with this shot that
looks like it could have come directly
out of a new hope then we get this
badass look at one of the villains in
the movie played by Ben Mendelsohn and
we don't know exactly who this is but
the insignia has most people thinking
he's either an admiral or a Grand
Admiral which would rank him even higher
than someone like grand moff tarkin who
by the way they might totally try to
sneak into this movie somewhere clearly
he's a big deal on the Death Star and
this could be the same room that Tarkin
eventually dies in so it would just be
really cool to see him come back also
regarding who this character is well the
Internet has a guess and I think they're
mostly basing it on the fact that there
is another Star Wars Admiral that is a
huge fan favorite and is also very fond
of wearing white no not him
this guy's name is Admiral Thrawn and
even if you haven't heard of him trust
me people love him and that's pretty
crazy because he's technically a bad guy
now yes Thrawn is blue but if you ignore
that for a moment let me tell you why
this Mendelssohn character could very
likely be based on him like I said
throne is one of the most famous
characters from the old Star Wars novels
that again
technically they're not Canon but this
guy did so much for the Star Wars saga
that they say he's one of the only
reasons people stayed interested in Star
Wars after the 80s during the 90s the
thron stories were considered the best
Star Wars additions that were happening
and for good reason they're good stories
as a Grand Admiral in the Empire this
guy actually had very little to do with
the force or the light side of the dark
side or the Sith of the Jedi's or
whatever he was just a military guy but
he was a badass military guy and just
like rogue one is about the badass
rebels who don't have any sort of magic
on their side this guy Thrawn was an
example of a version of the empire that
isn't about Sith Lords and more
importantly it's an empire that
you've never seen in the movie one where
the Imperial Navy is actually what you
should be most afraid of
for example admit it in the movies when
you see a Star Destroyer show up in the
atmosphere you get a little bit of like
an Auto feeling we also like math and a
wing can take out a super stardestroyer
pretty easily so maybe it's no big deal
but in the books
throw on is a very competent leader and
he's smarter than everybody else playing
the game and when he shows up with the
Star Destroyer you don't imagine anyone
can beat this Navy he's a chess master
and not only is thrown brilliant but
he's not even purely evil he doesn't
twirl a mustache or go on and on about
the power of the dark side he really is
just trying to restore order to the
galaxy and he's also very patient about
it instead of choking people when they
make mistakes he's very protective of
the lives of his men instead he chooses
to stay calm enough to think of a
brilliant plan that spares his people's
lives and still gets a strategic win so
we don't know if Mendelssohn's character
is wrong but he definitely could be
inspired by him which would be amazing a
non bumbling very threatening version of
the Imperial Navy makes a lot of sense
in a war movie and take a look at
Mendelsohn blaster he's holding
unlike previous Imperial leaders he
looks like he's willing to get down and
dirty himself and I think that might be
about to happen here actually that means
that this guy is definitely more of a
badass than a lot of the officers we've
encountered in the battle for the last
time
okay let's keep going what will you do
wouldn't I catch you alright if you look
closely behind this masked figure you'll
see there is a beast of a man or a beast
of a woman back there but look at those
freaking hands got mountain hands also
let's enhance on this shrouded face this
guy's is definitely up to something I
don't know what but it looks like it and
it's black eyes and his red skin this
could be a giant Lobster
okay or probably not but still I don't
wanna be crust racist but it would be
really badass if that's a relative of
Akbar's but anyway paying more attention
to the floating tank thing behind them
we've got a glimpse of some new home
tripper types on there I'm guessing
these are the rumored scarab troopers we
see a little more of them later and with
that and the shadow trooper that we're
about to see in a second you might think
okay how many different kinds of
troopers are they about to add in his
movie and I will point out that it is
actually a cool detail if you think
about it because this movie represents
the empire at the height of its power
once a new hope happens everything he's
got a down hill for them and the Empire
was only formed like 20 years earlier in
Revenge of the Sith so this is it like
right before they debut their mega
weapon they're at max level bossless
it's kind of like how in the 90s we had
the great economy and it made the
dot-com bubble there were all these
different kinds of coms or performing
left and right and nobody thought it
would ever end but then it all did and
then basically just Google survived and
I was like it that's the Empire with
stormtroopers we're so rich let's make
all of the troopers all kinds have a
sans ripper and a shadow trooper and a
rainbow trooper and then boom bubble
bursts and they're now like oh how about
we chill on the number of types of
stormtroopers we have by the way if you
are too young to get this dot-com
metaphor just think of apps and social
networks
that's the bubble we're in right now and
it's definitely a bubble you just wait
right it's gonna pop also there's
another reason why there are so many new
trooper types those of you that watch
our videos regularly know what I'm about
to say so stay with me toys it's always
about toys don't hate on toys though
they pay for bad ass movies watch my
Perlmutter video to hear about how
Mattel saved Marvel but anyway speaking
of toys here's another one that your
parents are gonna have to buy cuz this
tank thing that they're writing in it
seems like a totally new empire vehicle
but actually if you really
banco of your parents have them searched
for the 1984 toy that i think this is
based on it's the ast 5 mini rig and
remember if they don't find it still
wrapped in the original box they don't
love you moving on we get a glimpse of
Forest Whitaker's character who doesn't
have a name yet either he's walking with
a cane and he's got this out of breath
whisper thing going on what will you do
if you notice he's actually got an
oxygen mask and tube as part of his
outfit I don't have any idea who this is
but my current best guess is a grownup
version of the kid from Malcolm in the
Middle
I'll get into what this character is
talking about later as I mentioned now
we've got these shadow troopers too and
they seem to be the ultra elite of the
stormtroopers almost like they're SEAL
Team 6 by the way if you remember they
were the elite team from zero dark
thirty that I mentioned earlier so I
definitely could be really badass to see
these troopers up against our rebel
alley team especially since I bet these
will probably have good aim finally here
they seem to be investigating some sort
of crash site or destruction and yes
that's another moisture vaporators we
see the return of those handcuffs from
earlier but now on these rubble pilots
and again it makes you wonder are there
only one kind of handcuffs in this
universe which could totally be the case
or does this mean that jyn erso was
handcuffed by empire troops before and
then somehow ended up in the hands of
the rebels anyway I don't know let me
know what you think onward
what will you do they greet you here we
have gin and diego luna's character of
running away from someone in what looks
like an underground subway station I'm
just saying by the way that these two
look a lot like they are certain pair of
spy partners but anyway if you're
wondering why something that looks like
a subway station is in a Star Wars movie
keep in mind the thing is the size of a
moon of course they need some sort of
metro line now if you're wondering why
it seems like such a kind of familiar
subway station that might be because
you've been to London Canary Wharf
station notice the glass doors also
check out the not so subtle way they
covered up the Canary Wharf sign good
job guys
also two other things to know here one
hears that droid from before again but
do you notice this backplate that he's
rocking it's got that same oh I I
labeling that the stormtrooper back
plates due to Star Wars nerd trivia
moment the original designers call this
the doughnut and Twinkies
but this implies that this droid was
likely in service of the Empire and has
somehow switched sides and not to push
the Kyle Katarn stuff on us too much but
in that game Qatar has a lot of history
with a droid that looks a lot like this
the only thing is that's 8088 and he's
not really a good guy so that's not as
good a fit but still feels like kyle
katarn
also from what I've heard about this
droid he is an evolutionary love child
of the super battle droids from back in
the day and the EVAs palace oh and the
other thing I wanted to note here do you
see this could those be the Death Star
plans maybe it's too bad Star Wars
doesn't have the cloud cuz she could
just be like Mon Mothma I'm texting you
the Death Star plans
hey thanks bye moving on past the
Stormy's and the scarabs running we get
some action shots of Donnie Yen and mark
my words I think this guy is gonna be
the breakout badass from this movie
that's even more impressive when you
realize I'm pretty sure he's blind like
look at the way he walks and fights with
his eyes closed
he's also that poster of the whole cast
and he looks pretty freakin blind in
there with his milk eyes he reminds me a
lot of sticks from daredevil but
actually here's a cool theory I have
what if he's X Imperial whirl guard the
Royal Guard or the Red Guard they're the
best of the best when it comes
Imperial military their job is to
protect the Emperor so they're like The
Secret Service meets ninjas they're
known for their red garb and in fact
that could possibly be one of them in
the background right there inspecting
what looks like a crash next wing anyway
Donnie yen's character he's got this red
skirt like thing that could be part of
that old uniform but even cooler this bo
staff looking thing is using that could
be a vibe Roble that's the badass weapon
used by the Imperial Guard and now this
is all legit and I'm right that would
explain why all of these stormtroopers
are kind of acting like hey maybe we
don't need to fight this guy right now
maybe right like we can just talk this
out so obviously they're no match for
him but you know I really want to see
him fight these guys again they are
supposed to be the more elite of the
troopers so a bunch of them against one
of him that could be a fair fight
if these blaster guns look kinda
familiar to you that's because here
might be a huge nerd but also because
you might play a battlefront there the
11 rifles except these guys added these
barrel shrouds for some reason I bet
it's a really cool reason but I don't
know what it is also this section takes
place in a setting that we've never
really seen before in Star Wars Cancun
Mexico or probably not but we've almost
had no beaches in any of the movies
though yes I'm aware that there's been
like two that I can think of but
definitely not any that look like a
beautiful vacation destination they have
palm trees here though I know someone
who would still probably hate this beach
I don't like sand
it's coarse and it gets that everyone as
for what they're blowing up here there's
lots of debate about whose ship that is
but no one can deny that there's a lot
of similarities to Vader and kylo
shuttle so let's just guess that this
thing might belong to the Grand Admiral
from before and we do see him a second
later wading through water though
remember what I said about Thrawn notice
how like chill and patient this dude is
like look how he's just casually speed
walking through the water toward the
wreckage and all these dead troopers I
know that if getting the bottom of your
Cape wet is anything like when I get the
bottom of my jeans wet then that guy has
like all the patients I would be
throwing the biggest tantrum no my cape
is way too mad it's gross now it's
sticky also seen a bunch of trooper
bodies load in water that's a really
good example of knowing how to make
things feel like war war has casual
J'son just like how we kind of felt
something for a stormtrooper for the
very first time in force awakens' now
we're like damn man like war isn't good
for either side and that's pretty badass
when you're having realizations like
that that have some real-world
connections about a Star Wars movie this
movie's gonna have so many layers to it
I love it let's wrap this up if you
continue to fight
this to me is the most intriguing shot
of the entire trailer cuz who what where
also when and why this hooded figure
could be anyone except vapor I do not
think it's Vader but supposedly Mads
Mikkelsen is supposed to play a major
villain in the movie and we haven't even
seen him yet so maybe that's him but
also look who's flanking the scene two
imperial guards whose job it is to
protect the Emperor so could this be him
mmm I'd be with you on that guess if it
weren't for this little moment right
here where the hooded figure kneels that
definitely doesn't seem like a Palpatine
thing to do and okay that's not enough
to chew on then let's talk about what's
in front of him who's in there somebody
worth kneeling to my best guess about
this thing by the way is that it's a
back to tank we saw Luke healing in one
back in Return of the Jedi
now in there yeah I could totally
believe Vader's inside of that it also
would make sense that while he's healing
the Emperor would assign the guard to
protect him and yeah let's talk Vader
here's the thing about Vader in this
moment in time in the Star Wars rebels
TV show which is canon he was recently
in a very epic fight and he barely
survived it he liked the limps away he's
all hurt so this could be him recovering
from that fight but also because of the
fact that we know he's all good and
healthy in a new hope I'm actually so
pumped about the possibility of Vader
being there in that moment because if
that's him in the tank once he's out of
there it is going down no character in
the Star Wars universe has thicker plot
armor than Vader at this moment like
they can't just like kill him right
which means if he's showing up we know
he's getting out of this thing with
barely a scratch on him and so instead I
think we're gonna see him just own
everybody just slash and destroy and
murder and again this is just a guess
here but I predict if Vader does show up
which remember it at the beginning of a
new hope he's already been tasked with
getting the plans back so it would make
sense then I think that we will see the
most intense badass version of Darth
Vader we have ever seen so let's hope he
shows up all right let's skip ahead to
the epic beach moment just because it is
an amazing shock note how terrifying the
80 eighties seem in this moment that's
because our director here is a master of
making us feel so tiny when we're next
to epic sized monsters in fact compare
this shot to his other movie
monsters notice how he purposely keeps
the camera at human height it prevents
us from getting any other view than this
super intimidating wine also that movie
even opens with a really similar scene
to this where soldiers are taking on
these huge beasts also note the military
training on display here where some of
the rebels are running in a zigzag
pattern
but overall actually just more note
these psychos are running toward the
walkers except remember they aren't
Jedi's it's not like it's no big deal to
run that way either they have balls
bigger than Leroy Jenkins here or
they've also played battlefront and they
know that once you get to the back side
of them it's actually kind of easy to
take them down
Owen for those of you that cringed when
I said 8080 and you're like its back
I've said it before we contact to Disney
once about this is it at 480 18 yeah
good grief you're in the universe we'll
try to make sure that that Star Wars
character says 8080
they said it's 8080 but you know it's
never been said out loud in a Star Wars
movie and everywhere else it's a totally
mixed to answer so here's your chance
rogue one this is the first appearance
in the timeline of the movies you could
state it right here once and for all
just have gin like point over there and
be like hey look it's 80 eighties or
it's a dad's and then have her look
right into the camera and say there I
said it
that's how you say it it'll be worth it
just to settle all the stupid arguments
though I swear to God if she just says
and look it's Imperial Walker's I'm
gonna be so pissed I'm moving on what's
that sound like dish about you want to
bet it has something to do with why
they're running in that direction maybe
they are trying to get the plans off the
planet and that thing's blocking the
message or something maybe not but I
definitely get the vibe do they want to
blow that thing up and small spoiler
alert skip ahead if you're worried in
that earlier scene if that's the base of
the satellite then I'd say they're
probably successful in blowing it up and
all right the final shot of the trailer
what will you
a lot of people are talking about this
we've got gin or so doing her best
Katniss Everdeen impression she's
wearing black and pale armor that looks
like type I like garb but it's not
actually a type eyelet outfit and then
we hear Forest Whitaker what will you
become
obviously the editing wants us to think
that she maybe switches sides but I
don't think that's the case I think we
are definitely onto something with our
spy theory but if she were working for
the Empire and maybe she were some sort
of double agent or something well then
instead of Jan ORS I've got an alternate
theory
she could be Mara Jade Mara might be the
most popular of the Star Wars Expanded
Universe book characters and she's not
only the Emperor's hand at one point but
she goes on to be Luke Skywalker's wife
and not only does she end up being in a
badass Jedi in her own right she helps
raise a young little Jedi girl who
happened to be the child of Han and Leia
and her brother yeah he was a former
Jedi who turns to the dark side so you
can see that her turning out to be Mara
Jade yeah that could be incredibly epic
and launched a whole interesting
connection to the whole universe
I mean she's got these badass fighting
batons on her back she obviously knows
how to use them it would be very cool if
she taught a certain someone to fight
with a stick cuz you know she didn't
learn how to repel from Lu so maybe she
learned it from the rogue one but here's
a major flaw in this theory it's a teeny
tiny little one jyn erso yeah she could
totally die like way before ray is even
born in fact they could all die the
entire team there is no reason we should
expect anyone on this team to survive
this movie I know that's dark because
they're our heroes but as far as we know
at this point we don't see them again
after this and when you have a movie
where everybody knows technically how
it's gonna end the plans do make it to
Leia then how do you add trauma to it
you make us fall in love with a bunch of
characters and then you make us squirm
at realizing they all might die it
actually ends up being a brilliant move
to avoid a lot of the existing Star Wars
characters because here this will they
even survive this movie feeling that we
have that is so rare because
course Luke is gonna survive of course
ray is gonna survive of course Han yeah
you get my point
it's always so obvious it's not often
that we are extremely worried about the
character surviving before we've even
seen the freaking movie and that right
there is why I'm so stressed out hurry
December cannot come soon enough I need
to see this movie oh and no I didn't
forget the cool thing that they did with
the music here they make you think
you're just listening to the four-seam
again
the underneath they sneak in the
Imperial March
it just makes this question what the
hell is going on here what side are
people on but also while we're over
analyzing the audio did you hear the
breath there's a lot of debate hear that
right in the middle of the word become
what will you you can hear Darth Vader's
breath like what will you become
I'm actually not entirely clear it's not
just the asthma man's echoey voice so
actually questions for you to chat about
in the comments and wrack your brain
trying to figure out with me one is that
Vader's breathing there at the air - do
you think any of these characters are
gonna survive this movie three do you
think this is Jenner so as a version of
Jan ors or do you think she's Mar Jade
and is this guy Grand Admiral Thrawn for
who's in the back to tank and who's in
the hood at Joan at Lally thinks they
could be Snoke no no here's a random
guess from me for who the hooded person
could be I don't think this is likely
actually but it would be so badass if it
was Darth Maul yep he did not die but
that is a long story for a different day
question 5 what familiar characters are
gonna show up in this movie I know we
talked about Vader but what about Leia
this movie could theoretically
transition directly into a new hope like
just cut out the opening scroll Leia's
ship receives the plans so will we see
her or maybe hear her over speaker I for
one am hoping we see Bail Organa because
that dude was supposed to be very
important in setting up the Rebel
Alliance according to that same deleted
scene from Revenge of the Sith and he's
supposed to be on Alderaan when it blows
up so I would love to see him there all
on this planet actually get to know this
planet and these people before it gets
blown up we've actually only ever seen
it for a few seconds in the last prequel
okay that is obviously a ton of stuff to
figure out so get to commenting or if
you want to discuss these points with me
we can chat about it on my Twitter at
fimo or on my Facebook page facebook.com
slash Teemo knows that's also by the way
where I get the tweets and posts that
you see show up in the video from those
pages as always you can follow at new
rock stars on Twitter to keep up with
our video schedule and if you're aching
for more Star Wars content go watch our
force awakens full movie breakdown watch
it alongside the new blu-ray maybe that
you just got
I reveal all sorts of amazing things in
there so check it out while you watch
the movie alright
I am completely
breakdown down so I will just have to
see you next time have a good one bye